[Music]
jeff goldblum returning to the jurassic
universe japanese spider-man joining the
spider-verse daniel craig breaking out
that kentucky fried accent again for
knives out 2. 2022 is shaping up to be a
fun year for movies here's what we're
looking forward to the most
after more than three decades of
regularly getting new live action batman
films you think there's nowhere this
franchise could go next but the
marketing for the batman makes it look
like this new matt reeves feature could
offer something new and extremely
exciting
specifically the productions trailers
have emphasized a film noir aesthetic
that appears to merge the maximalist
visual sensibilities of tim burton's
take on the dark knight with the grimy
tangibility of christopher nolan's
interpretation of the character
meanwhile the film's vision of the
riddler played by paul dano appears more
like the zodiac killer than jim carrey's
over over-the-top incarnation from
batman forever that's good not just in
terms of offering up something different
from older batman movies it also teases
a version of batman that's more about
his detective skills than exclusively
punching people those promising concepts
are paired up with the equally
intriguing casting of robert pattinson
in the titular role the good time
leading man already looks like he's
brewing something special with his take
on bruce wayne
batman
inventions
combine this cast with all the striking
imagery seen in the film's initial
trailers and it becomes clear why even
after so many other batman movies it's
hard not to get excited about the
possibilities that lie within the batman
the 2022 marvel cinematic universe title
that everyone is watching with
especially intense interest is black
panther wakanda forever ryan coogler is
back in the director's chair while the
majority of the first film's cast has
also returned there's also new cast
members like michaela cole and dominique
thorne with the latter portraying riri
williams ironheart rumors also persist
that the forever purge leading man
tinoch huerta has been cast as namor the
submariner who would make his
live-action film debut if he appeared in
wakanda forever a sequel to a pop
culture phenomenon like black panther
would have always garnered people's
interests however the tragic passing of
chadwick boseman has added a new layer
of uncertainty to wakanda forever
typically it's easy to see where a
sequel to a superhero movie is going
with its storyline but all kinds of
questions surround wakanda forever what
will a black panther movie without
bozeman look like what story does
wakanda forever explore how will
established characters react to the
sudden absence of t'challa the shadow of
bozeman lingers over wakanda forever and
ensures that this won't be a
run-of-the-mill superhero sequel
considering we've gotten eight different
live-action spider-man movies it was
only a matter of time before the
oscar-winning spider-man into the
spider-verse got a follow-up currently
without a name it is known that this
installment in the series will add a
trio of new versions of spider-man to
the past including japanese spider-man
and a version of jessica drew
spider-woman voiced by issa rae producer
and co-writer christopher miller teased
last year on twitter that the sequel
will explore even wilder visual
directions than its already vibrant
predecessor the endless amount of
imagination in the first spider-verse
makes the prospect of a sequel extremely
enticing no no no no you guys don't get
it don't get what
while some superhero movie sequels end
up just regurgitating the original
movie's plot points again the use of
multiple universes in spiderverse
inherently means there are limitless
possibilities for the tales this film
could explore
it'll also be interesting to see if this
sequel ends up building on the
post-credits scene of the first
spider-verse which not only introduced
spider-man 2099 voiced by oscar isaac
but outfitted him with a watch that
allowed him to travel between dimensions
with ease
those dinosaurs are stomping back into
movie theaters next summer with jurassic
world dominion which will follow up on
the events of jurassic world fallen
kingdom and take place in a world where
dinosaurs now roam free in america exact
plot details are being kept under lock
and key but it's known that the cast for
dominion will include original jurassic
park leads sam neil laura dern and jeff
goldblum reprising the roles the return
of this trio is already enough to get
jurassic park fans stoked to see
dominion but moviegoers should also get
excited about newcomer cast members like
mama duache and dewanda weiss who
promised to inject new personality into
the series for those who think this
franchise has gone extinct jurassic
world dominion certainly has the
potential to show that life or at least
a jolt of creativity finds a way
can you believe it's been 25 years since
the original mission impossible lit the
fuse and blew up everyone's expectations
for what a movie adaptation of an old tv
show could be
so hard to keep track of these things
rather than leaning on fan service and
hollow rehashes of familiar storylines
from its source material the mission
impossible series keeps on delivering
fresh new stunts and exciting story
lines to keep moviegoers across the
globe guessing with all these
achievements under the franchise's belt
no wonder people are so excited to see
what lies in store for ethan hunt in
mission impossible 7. there are also
lots of new cast members joining this
particular adventure esai morales is on
board to play the primary villain while
hayley adwell is portraying someone
described on the light the fuse podcast
as a destructive force of nature as if
those two weren't enough shae wiggum
palm clementife and carrie elwes among
many others are also taking on new
characters in this sprawling series then
of course there are the stunts which
apparently include crews riding a dirt
bike off a cliff what more could you
want
for years aquaman was a punchline but
the 2018 aquaman movie became a surprise
monster hit grossing 1.14 billion
dollars worldwide and securing the title
of highest grossing dc comics adaptation
at the worldwide box office all eyes are
now on the film's sequel aquaman and the
lost kingdom to see if the momentum
behind this character could be
maintained
i have no leader
i'm not a king
i do not work or play well with others
james wan is back in the director's
chair for this installment and both
jason mamoa and amber heard are
returning yaya abdul mateen ii is also
coming back in a much more prominent
capacity as the super villain david kane
black monta it's nice to know there's a
capable cast involved but what people
really want out of an aquaman movie is
all the staggering spectacle its
predecessor delivered if one can deliver
on that then aquaman won't ever have to
worry about being reduced to a punchline
again
avatar debuted back in 2009 and did huge
numbers usually a movie that impacts the
global box office like that james
cameron epic will receive a barrage of
sequels in short order but cameron has
taken his time in crafting follow-ups to
avatar which has resulted in countless
release date delays even before the
covet 19 pandemic threw a wrench into
the production of all four sequels the
first of these sequels is set for a
december 2022 release and even after all
this waiting the world of pandora still
seems surprisingly intriguing for one
thing cameron is good at creating
cinematic spectacles period second
projects like aliens and terminator 2
judgement day show the camera knows how
to make sequels that aren't just hollow
rehashes of the past the extensive
weight between the original avatar and
the first of its sequels also gives one
hope that cameron and company have spent
that time wisely to make this
blockbuster as good as it can be no one
knows if the world is still craving more
avatar like it was in 2009 but the
reputation of cameron ensures that
avatar 2 is one of the most intriguing
cinematic question marks of 2022
one good murder mystery deserves another
so benoit blanc is back after knives out
became a smash it was only inevitable
that the world would be greeted with
further blanc adventures classic sleuths
like hercule quarrel got called back for
countless further mysteries so why
shouldn't blanc also solve an endless
series of eccentric cases
my presence will be
automatical
daniel craig is the only returning cast
member for this sequel a welcome
indicator that this follow-up doesn't
intend to just play like a rerun of its
predecessor knives out 2 has assembled a
crop of brand new famous faces for blanc
to contend with from dave bautista to
catherine hahn to ethan hawke it isn't
just in the cast that knives out 2 hopes
to deliver something fresh an
international backdrop also promises to
differentiate this follow-up from its
predecessor as does a netflix premiere
instead of a theatrical release
if you thought the toy story saga came
to an end with toy story 4 think again
lightyear is the newest entry in the
franchise and delivers to moviegoers the
original story that the buzz lightyear
toy is based on that's an elaborate
setup for what appears to be pixar's
attempt at doing a more jovial sci-fi
film after delivering a weightier take
on the genre with the 2008 feature
wall-e it also allows the toy division
of disney to sell a whole new army of
buzz lightyear toys to kids worldwide
which is never a bad thing for the mouse
house light year doesn't sound like an
essential movie on paper but pixar has
been rolling nothing but aces when it
comes to the toy story franchise even
after toy story 3 seemed to conclude the
saga on a perfect note toy story 4
managed to deliver a poignant epilogue
for the story of woody the cowboy if it
lives up to its potential lightyear
could prove to be a worthy return to the
toy story universe after all
it's been a while since south korean
cinema legend park chanwook delivered a
new feature film to movie theaters his
last film the captivatingly twisty the
handmaiden was one of his very best
works making the wait for this next
motion picture all the more difficult to
endure however this master of
unpredictable cinema like old boy
appears poised to finally return to the
big screen with his new feature decision
to leave the scanplot details that have
been revealed indicate that decision to
leave follows a detective who gets
embroiled in a romance with a murder
suspect however this is one movie where
the director is reason enough to keep an
eye on the project
it's been too long since a twisted new
vision from director david cronenberg
arrived in theaters the body horror
auteur behind projects ranging from
scanners to a history of violence is
responsible for some of the most
unsettling storylines and images ever to
exist in the medium of cinema now it
appears cronenberg will have an
opportunity to add another sterling
effort to his filmography with the 2022
movie crimes of the future this project
will serve not just as cronenberg's
return to filmmaking but also to one of
his earliest movies crimes of the future
is a remake of a 1970 cronenberg feature
of the same name only his second
directorial effort at the time
comments from viggo mortensen to gq
about the project indicate that anyone
expecting a mere shot for shock remake
of an old feature needs to adjust their
expectations it sounds like cronenberg
is brewing up something new and bold
having apparently already completed
principal photography it's only a matter
of time now before the first cronenberg
movie since maps to the stars in 2014
grace's movie screens everywhere long
live the new flesh or the return of
cronenberg
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
new movies are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you